This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. One of the most exciting things in sports is to see a truly great player shatter all previous assumptions about what is possible to achieve in the game. But while fans applaud and announcers lose their minds, opposing teams scrambled to find strategies to stop these grades. In basketball they tried to stop Shaquille O'Neill by immediately fouling him when he got the ball so that he'd have to shoot from the free throw line, which he wasn't very good at. This strategy became known as the Hacker Shack. As we immediately have a Hacker Shack call, I don't believe it. Five seconds in. In soccer, opposing teams continuously filed the great Argentinian player Leo Messi to keep
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。体育运动中最令人兴奋的事情之一，就是看到一位真正伟大的球员打破了人们对比赛成就的所有既定假设。但当球迷们欢呼雀跃、解说员们为之疯狂时，对手球队却在绞尽脑汁寻找策略来阻止这些伟大的球员。在篮球比赛中，他们试图通过在沙奎尔·奥尼尔接球时立即对他犯规来阻止他，这样他就必须在罚球线上投篮，而这并不是他的强项。这种策略被称为“砍鲨战术”（Hack-a-Shaq）。我们立刻听到了“砍鲨战术”的哨声，简直不敢相信。才过了五秒钟。在足球比赛中，对手球队不断地对阿根廷巨星莱昂内尔·梅西犯规，以阻止他带球突破防线。球直接越过头顶，落到了梅西的膝盖上。这简直太离谱了。这些阻止伟大球员的战术可能极具侵略性，而且往往游走在规则的边缘。今天为我们讲述这个故事的是尼尔·佩恩。他来自ESPN旗下的数据新闻网站538。但在棒球运动中，他们采取了不同的做法。在棒球比赛中，阻止史上最伟大击球手的解决方案竟然是重新设计这项运动本身。
him from dribbling through their defense. It's right over the top into the knee of Messi's patch. It is absolutely scandalous. These tactics to stop the great players can be aggressive, and they often stretch the limits of the rulebook. That's Neil Payne bringing us our story today. He's from 538, the data journalism site owned by ESPN. But in baseball, they did it differently. In baseball, the solution to stopping the greatest hitter of all time was to actually redesign
这一切始于20世纪40年代，主角是伟大的泰德·威廉姆斯。他曾有名言，说他长大后想成为有史以来最伟大的击球手。本·布拉德利二世撰写了泰德·威廉姆斯的权威传记。在比赛前的更衣室里，他会立起一面镜子，脱得只剩内衣，挥动球棒说：“我是泰德·威廉姆斯，我是有史以来最棒的击球手。”请原谅我的粗鲁。泰德·威廉姆斯并不谦虚，但他说的也没错。1941年，这位年轻的红袜队超级巨星以406的打击率结束了这一年，
the game itself. It all started in the 1940s with the great Ted Williams. Famously, he would say that when he grew up he wanted to be the greatest hitter or whoever lived. Ben Bradley Jr. wrote the definitive biography of Ted Williams. Before a game in the clubhouse, he would put up a mirror and strip down to his skivvy's and swing a bat and say, I'm Ted Williams, I'm the best f***er and hitter who ever lived. Pardon my French. Not a humble man, Ted Williams, but also not wrong. In 1941, the young Red Sox superstar finished the year with a batting average of 406,
这意味着他在超过40%的击球中都打出了安打，这简直好得不可思议。自泰德·威廉姆斯之后，再没有人打出过400以上的打击率。他是所有击球手中最伟大的一位。威廉姆斯一直保持着这种状态。他甚至离开去参加了第二次世界大战，回来后依然是棒球界最棒的击球手。但在1946年，就在泰德·威廉姆斯有望再次打破纪录时，他遇到了一个一心想终结他连胜纪录的人。那个人是克利夫兰棒球队的卢·布德罗。布德罗是印第安人队的游击手，但他同时也是球队的经理。因为在那个年代，你确实可以同时担任球员和经理。他是一个非常有野心的人，也是一位伟大的球员。但尽管布德罗很成功，却有另一位球员吸引了所有的目光。
meaning that he got a hit in over 40% of his at-bats, which is incredibly good. No one has batted above 400 since Ted Williams. The greatest hitter of them all. And Williams kept it up. He even left to fight in World War II, came back, and was still the best hitter in baseball. But in 1946, just as Ted Williams was on track for another record-breaking year, he came face-to-face with someone hell-bent on ending his streak. A guy with the Cleveland baseball team named Lu Boudreau. Boudreau was a shortstop for the Indians, but he was also the manager of the team. Because back then, you could actually be both a player and a manager at the same time. He was an incredibly ambitious person and a great player. But despite Boudreau's success, there was this other player that got all the attention.
泰德·威廉姆斯，有史以来最伟大的击球手。威廉姆斯占据了大部分头条新闻，并因作为一名如此伟大的击球手而备受赞誉。那是拉塞尔·施耐德。他曾为《克利夫兰老实人报》报道印第安人队，并与卢·布德罗关系密切。据我所知，毫无疑问，这是威廉姆斯和布德罗之间的一场自我较量。但布德罗有一个计划。他知道威廉姆斯几乎总是把球打向球场的右侧，即一垒和二垒之间。作为印第安人队的经理，他实际上可以专门制定球队策略来击败威廉姆斯。小伙子们私下议论说，克利夫兰经理卢·布德罗正在熬夜为他们策划一种新型的防守战术。
Ted Williams, the greatest hitter who ever lived. Williams got most of the headlines, praise, for as what of being such a great hitter. That's Russell Schneider. He covered the Indians for the Cleveland plane dealer and became close with Lou Boudreau. Knowing Boudreau as I think I did, there's no doubt that this was a clash of he goes between Williams and Boudreau. But Boudreau had a plan. He knew that Williams almost always hit the ball to the right side of the field between first and second base. As the Indians manager, he could actually set up his team's strategy specifically to beat Williams. The boys whispered that Blue Bull Drow, Cleveland manager, is running the Midnight Oil for facting a new type of defense for them.
布德罗对球队说：“我厌倦了让威廉姆斯击败我们。这就是我想做的。”卢·布德罗决定将三名球员从球场左侧调到右侧。他在一垒和二垒之间筑起了一道由三名内野手组成的墙，身后还有三名外野手作为后盾。现在，七名防守队员中有六名站在球场右侧。左侧只剩下一名孤零零的外野手。
Blue said to Hound, and he said, I'm tired of having Williams beat us. And this is what I want to do. Blue Bull Drow decided that he would shift three players from the left side of the field to the right. He put a wall of three infielders between first and second base with a trio of outfielders backed up behind them. Now six of the seven defenders were standing on the right side of the field. Only one lonely outfielder remained on the left.
棒球场熟悉的对称性被打破了。随之，“泰德·威廉姆斯布阵”（The Ted Williams shift）诞生了。我称之为“布德罗布阵”。有些人称之为“防守布阵”或简称为“布阵”。布德罗第一次对威廉姆斯使用这种布阵是在1946年7月14日的芬威球场。当威廉姆斯走上打击区，第一次看到这种布阵时，他问裁判：“那外面到底在搞什么鬼？”
The familiar symmetry of the baseball diamond had been disrupted. And with it, the Ted Williams shift was born. I call it the budro shift. Some people call it the defensive shift or just the shift. The first time budro used the shift on Williams was July 14, 1946 at Fenway Park. When Williams stepped into the plate and saw the shift for the first time, he said the umpire, what the hell is going on out there?
“他们不能那样做。”但他们确实可以，这完全合法。所以威廉姆斯面临一个选择：像往常一样挥棒，他可能会打出本垒打，但也可能把球打进防守队员的手中，因为他们已经向右侧移动了；或者他可以走出舒适区，尝试把球打向左侧。
They can't do that. But they could, totally legal. And so Williams had a choice. Swing just like he'd always swung, and he might hit a home run. But he might also hit the ball into the crowd to defend her, shifted to his right. Or he could go outside his comfort zone and try to hit the ball to the left.
布德罗知道泰德很难改变他的挥棒方式，因为他是一个强力击球手，一个本垒打手，因此他会继续坚持自己的方式。这是再次引用布拉德利的话，他撰写了泰德·威廉姆斯的传记。他是在利用威廉姆斯的自尊心。这奏效了。威廉姆斯第一次上场打击时，就直接打进了布阵的“牙齿”里。事实上，他把球直接打向了站在一垒和二垒之间的布德罗本人。
Boudreau knew that it would be difficult for Ted to alter his swing, so I'm self as a slugger, a home run hitter, and therefore he would continue doing it his way. That's been Bradley again, who wrote the Ted Williams biography. He was appealing to Williams' pride. And it worked. The first time Williams came up to bat, he hit straight into the teeth of the shift. In fact, he hit the baseball right to Boudreau himself, standing directly between first and second
布德罗继续对威廉姆斯使用这种布阵，很快，其他球队也开始对他使用。没过多久，可能就在一两周内，整个美国联盟都采用了这种战术。威廉姆斯辩称，不，他不会改变自己自然的挥棒方式，球迷们来到球场是为了看他击球。在采访中，威廉姆斯说他认为这种布阵让他的职业生涯打击率下降了约15个百分点。
base. Boudreau kept using the shift on Williams, and pretty soon, other teams were using it against him too. It wasn't long at all. Maybe within a week or two that the rest of the American League was adopting it. Williams argued that, no, he wasn't going to alter his natural swing, that the fans were showing up at the park to see him hit. In interviews, Williams said he thought the shift shaved about 15 points off of his
事实上，这可能是唯一一个真正对泰德·威廉姆斯产生影响的战术。最终，泰德·威廉姆斯退役了，这种布阵也或多或少地从棒球界消失了。许多经理对使用它持犹豫态度，因为它并不总是有效。当效果不好时，你会显得很尴尬。这是《防守圣经》（The Fielding Bible）的作者约翰·德万，你可以放心地称他为“布阵数据教父”。他说，很长一段时间以来，
lifetime batting average. In fact, it's probably the only tactic that ever actually had an effect on Ted Williams. Eventually, Ted Williams retired, and the shift, it more or less disappeared from baseball. A lot of managers were hesitant to use it, because it didn't always work. When it goes bad, you look bad. This is John DeWon, the author of the Fielding Bible, and a guy you'd be safe calling the Godfather of Shift Data. And he says, for a long time,
球队并没有那种能支持“风险随时间推移会有回报”这一想法的数据。你知道，在70年代和80年代，并没有真正强大的分析技术能告诉你这种方法会奏效。但后来“赛伯计量学”（Sabermetrics）出现了。赛伯计量学是棒球界在90年代兴起的一场运动，旨在收集数据并进行研究以寻找优势。突然间，大联盟各队的总经理和管理层都专注于这样一个理念：要在不花大钱的情况下获胜，你所要做的就是看数据。
teams didn't have the kind of data that would back up the idea that risk would pay off over time. You know, there weren't real strong analytics back in the 70s and 80s that could tell you this kind of thing would work. But then Saber metrics came along. Saber metrics is a movement in baseball that started in the 90s to collect data and study it to find advantages. Suddenly, GMs and front offices across the major leagues were focused on this idea that to win without spending much money, all you had to do was look at the numbers.
坦帕湾魔鬼鱼队（现更名为光芒队）登场了。在很长一段时间里，它被认为是棒球界最糟糕的球队。这是乔纳·凯里，一位为光芒队写过书的记者。他们只是不明白获胜需要什么。这是糟糕的棒球。四次防守失误让魔鬼鱼队在第八局付出了惨痛的代价。但光芒队的情况在21世纪中期开始发生变化。高盛前合伙人斯图尔特·斯特恩伯格决定买下这支球队。
Enter the Tampa Bay rays, formerly known as the Devil Rays. It was regarded as maybe the worst franchise in all of baseball for quite a while. That's Jonah Kerry, a journalist who wrote a book about the Rays. They just didn't really understand what it took to win. This is bad baseball. Four defensive miscues have cost the double raise dearly in the eighth. But things started changing for the race in the mid-2000s. Stuart Sternberg, former partner Goldman Sachs, decided he was going to buy the team.
他带来了一群华尔街类型的人。你知道，数字专家，量化分析师。那些擅长利用数据寻找隐藏优势的人。他的理论是，让我们成功，比竞争对手好2%就行。光芒队的数字分析师研究了数据，他们发现了一种非常有效的战术，可以帮助他们的防守。这是一种从棒球遥远的过去挖掘出来的战术。你猜对了，就是防守布阵。
And with him, he brought a bunch of other Wall Street types. You know, number guys, quants. Guys who were good at using data to find hidden advantages. His theory was, let's just succeed and be 2% better than the competition. The raised number cruncher studied the data, and they discovered a really efficient tactic that could help their fielding in defense. A tactic dredged up from baseball's distant past. You guessed it, the defensive shift.
布阵确实是额外2%优势的完美例子，因为坦率地说，布阵并不总是有效。事实上，它经常失败。但光芒队没什么可失去的，所以他们决定冒险带回这种布阵。他们聘请了一位支持他们计划的经理，一个名叫乔·马登的人。马登立刻开始对各种不同的击球手使用这种布阵。
The shift really is a perfect example of an extra 2% advantage, because the shift frankly doesn't work all the time. In fact, it fails quite a bit. But the rays didn't have much to lose, so they decided to take a risk and bring back the shift. And they hire manager for the team who's on board with their plan, a guy by the name of Joe Madden. And right away, Madden starts using the shift on all kinds of different hitters.
乔·马登，他是防守布阵的博士和大师。有趣的布阵，我们还没见过针对哈迪的这种布阵。但乔·马登今年想出了各种有趣的布阵。我的意思是，你不会经常看到针对像佩拉尔塔这样的人使用这种布阵。突然之间，这支曾经的灾难性球队，变成了一支你无法从他们的投手身上得分的严密球队。滚地球传向二垒。他有他的强臂。
Joe Madden, he's got the doctor and the master of the defensive shift. Interesting shift, we haven't really seen one like this against Hardy. But Joe Madden has come up with all kinds of interesting shifts this year. I mean, you don't really ride C, this type of shift all that often against a guy like Peralta. And all of a sudden, it's just this disaster of a team. Become this airtight team that you can't score runs off their pitchers. Ground ball to second. He'll ever have his gun.
光芒队展现了实力。他们从一支长期沉睡的球队，奇迹般地转型为冠军争夺者。而布阵正是他们复兴的核心。布阵流行起来了。突然间，联盟中的每支球队都开始使用布阵。事实上，其他球队开始针对光芒队自己最好的击球手使用布阵，包括这个人。我叫卡洛斯·佩尼亚，我打了14个赛季的大联盟棒球。
Raise your gun. From nowhere, they transformed themselves from a perpetual dormant to a championship contender. And the shift was right at the center of their resurgence. The shift caught on. All of a sudden, every team the league started shifting. In fact, other teams began shifting against the Rey's own best hitters, including this guy. My name is Carlos Pena, and I play
卡洛斯·佩尼亚小时候在多米尼加共和国长大，他认为成为一名强力击球手是他前往美国的入场券。“我们必须靠挥棒离开岛屿，我们必须这样做，这就是我们被教导的方式。如果我们想进入大联盟，最好是为了力量而挥棒。”卡洛斯·佩尼亚，一个飞球打向右外野深处，一路飞向看台。他确实为了力量而挥棒。
Major League Baseball for 14 seasons. Carlos Pena grew up playing baseball as a kid in the Dominican Republic, and being a power hitter, he believed, was his ticket to the US. We swing our way off the island, we have to, that's the way we were taught. If we want to make it to Medjolique, you better be swinging for some power. Carlos Panias, and there's a fly ball deep to right field, way back to the Lanskore. And swing for power, he did.
卡洛斯·佩尼亚在2007年效力于光芒队时打出了46支本垒打。就在同一时间，乔·马登正在将布阵重新引入大联盟。又是一个高飞球打回右外野。走！佩尼亚打出了第46支。
Carlos Panias hit 46 home runs in 2007 while playing for the raise. Right around the same time, Joe Madden was reintroducing the shift to the major leagues. And there's a high fly ball back into right field. Go! Pena hits number 46.
那是2007年。我打了46支。2008年，他们对我使用了布阵。而布阵绝对是杀手。滚地球，直接打进布阵的牙齿里，洛佩兹从右外野短处传球淘汰佩尼亚，风吹向他，他挥棒。你知道，就像，等一下，你知道，
That was 2007. I had 46. 2008, I had the shift on me. And the shift is absolutely a killer. Ground ball, right into the teeth of the shift that Lopez from short right field throws out Pavia, wind and pits to him, and he swings. You know, like, wait a second, you know,
我职业生涯剩下的时间都要这样吗？果然，事情就是这样发生的。他把球打向了约翰逊，约翰逊在布阵中正好守在一垒和二垒之间。即使是像佩尼亚这样的伟大球员，也不可能一直打出本垒打。当佩尼亚面对布阵时，他必须做出决定：是坚持我自然的挥棒方式，也许能打出本垒打，但也可能直接打进布阵中，还是改变我的挥棒方式？
is this good the way he's going to be, you know, for the rest of my career? And sure enough, that's exactly what happened. And he lied to this one right to Johnson, who had him played between first and second in the shift. Even the grades like Panieth can't hit home runs all the time. When Panieth was shifted on, he had to make a decision. Do I swing my natural swing and maybe get a home run, or maybe hit straight into the shift, or do I change my
最终，与威廉姆斯不同——威廉姆斯的自尊心驱使他试图强行突破布阵——佩尼亚开始采取另一种战术。他做了一件泰德·威廉姆斯整个职业生涯只尝试过几次的事情。布阵针对佩尼亚。他向三垒方向短打。卡洛斯·佩尼亚，短打。谦逊的短打。这个动作一点也不漂亮。
swing? Eventually, unlike Williams, whose ego led him to try to power through the shift, Pena started to adopt another tactic. He did something Ted Williams had only tried a handful of times during his whole career. Shift is on for Pania. And he bunched the ball third base side. Carlos Pania, bunched. The humble bunch. There's nothing pretty about this move.
你只是用球棒轻轻碰一下球，球就滚到了场上。短打是球员传统上用来将队友从一个垒包推进到另一个垒包的手段。对卡洛斯·佩尼亚来说，他把短打变成了自己的秘密武器。利用短打，佩尼亚可以把球轻轻点向三垒方向，那里没有人防守。这在很多时候都很有效，即使他并不总是觉得使用这种战术很舒服。“感觉就像我认输了。你知道，就像我在说，好吧，你们赢了。我只是要短打。”
You just kind of bonk the ball with your bat and it dribbles out onto the field. Bunting was something that players traditionally did just to move their teammates from one base to another. For Carlos, Pania turned the Bunt into his own secret weapon. Using the Bunt, Pania could tap the ball toward third base, where no one was around to pick it up. And it worked a lot of the time, even if he didn't always feel good about using it. It felt like I was giving in. You know, like I was saying, okay, you guys got me. I'm just gonna buy.
这听起来有点傻，但实际上，有时作为自尊心很强的运动员，我们会有这种想法。就像，不，伙计，好好打比赛。佩尼亚知道他必须吞下自己的自尊，但这违背了他成长过程中学到的一切。“我从小看着本垒打长大，本垒打，本垒打。我只想打本垒打。那是受到赞美的东西。”
That's kind of silly, but in reality, sometimes there's prideful athletes. We think that. Like, no, man, play the game. Payne knew he had the swallow is prined, but it went against everything he had learned growing up. I grew up watching home runs, home runs, home runs. And all I wanted to do was hit home runs. That's what was celebrated.
你知道，没有人会说：“那是个很棒的短打，孩子。”是的。不过，佩尼亚的短打确实很棒。在他职业生涯的某个阶段，他面对布阵时的短打成功率是25投15中。卡洛斯·佩尼亚成为了大联盟中面对布阵最频繁的短打者之一。内角快速球。
You know, no one said, that's great bun, son. Yeah. PANYES Buns, though, they were actually great. At one point in his career, he was 15 for 25 on Buns against the ship. Carlos PANYO becomes one of the most prolific bunters in the majors against the shift. Fast ball inside.
球被短打了。怎么样？精彩的战术。佩尼亚在两好球的情况下完成了短打。佩尼亚说，他在对抗布阵方面的成功确实改变了比赛的打法，但他对此并不高兴。“伙计，布阵……这简直是……一种折磨。布阵是我希望他们能废除的东西。”
And it's buttoned. How about that? Great play. A two strike button by Pena. Pena says his success at combating the shift has actually changed the way the game has played, but he's not happy about it. Man, the shift is played, but he's not happy about it. The shift is just a...hemmises. A shift is something that I wish they could get rid of.
新任棒球专员罗伯·曼弗雷德实际上同意佩尼亚的观点。他正在与ESPN讨论如何改进比赛。“像取消布阵这样的事情，我会对这些想法持开放态度。”曼弗雷德认为布阵让比赛变得不那么令人兴奋，因为它让球队更难得分。他还认为现在这种情况发生得太多了。在许多方面，关于布阵的争论已经演变成了一场关于比赛本质的争论。自从赛伯计量学出现以来，棒球球迷、专家和球员们一直对“场上决策基本上是数据分析的产物”这一观点感到不满。
New baseball commissioner Rob Manfred actually agrees with painting. He is talking to ESPN about how he wants to improve the game. Things like eliminating shifts, I would be open to those sorts of ideas. Manfred thinks the shift makes the game less exciting because it makes it harder for teams to score runs. He also thinks it's just happening too much now. In many ways the fight about the shift has become a fight over the nature of the game. Ever since say, Rometrics came along, baseball fans and pundits and players have bristled at the idea that on-field decisions are basically a product of data analysis.
这对许多球员来说可能是令人抓狂的，就像是：“等等，这个从哈佛来的、从未投过棒球的孩子，正在决定我的未来。”哦，那种愤怒，球员们简直无法相信。但除非规则改变，否则球场上会继续使用布阵，因为它有效。“哦，这太重要了。这真的非常重要。”据《防守圣经》作者约翰·德万说，它每年可以帮助球队多赢大约三场比赛，这意义重大。
That could be maddening to many players, it's like, wait, this kid from Harvard, who has never thrown a baseball. It's deciding my future. Oh, that anger's, players like you wouldn't believe. But unless there's a rule change, the field will keep shifting because it works. Oh, it's huge. It is really huge. According to John DeWan, the author of The Fielding Bible, it can help win about three extra
“三场胜利，我认为每年都能决定一支球队能否进入季后赛。”球队不会放弃这种竞争优势。所以现在这是数字专家和传统主义者之间，书呆子和运动员之间，关于决定比赛设计的斗争。与此同时，如果我的孩子们决定打棒球，我一定会告诉他们：“干得好，孩子。”《99%隐形》本周与ESPN旗下的数据新闻网站538合作。节目由乔·赛克斯制作，乔迪·阿伯根编辑，凯蒂·明格尔为《99PI》改编。
games a year, which is significant. Three wins, I think every single year, has separated a team from getting into the playoffs or not. Teams are not going to give up that competitive advantage. So now it's a fight between the number guys and the traditionalists, between the nerds and the jocks to decide the design of the game. In the meantime, if my boys ever decide to take a baseball, I'm going to make sure and tell them, great fun, son. 99% of visible was a collaboration this week with 538, the data journalism site owned by ESPN. It was produced by Joe Sykes with editing from Jodi Abergan, and adapted for 99PI by Katie Mingle.
特别感谢体育记者尼尔·佩恩。尼尔是538体育播客《Hot Takedown》的嘉宾，他们正在制作一系列名为《超越时代》（Ahead of Their Time）的纪录片，讲述那些在当时做着激进事情却未被赏识的球员和教练。你可以在538.com/podcasts找到它们，或者在你的播客应用中搜索《Hot Takedown》。《99%隐形》的成员包括上述的凯蒂·明格尔，以及库尔特·科尔斯、谢丽·福塞夫、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特罗尔曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎、德莱尼·霍尔，以及我，罗曼·马斯。
Special thanks to Sports Reporter Neil Payne. Neil is a panelist on 538 Sports Podcast Hot Take Down, and they're doing a whole series of documentaries called Ahead of Their Time, about players and coaches who were doing something radical, but weren't appreciated in their era. You can find them all at 538.com slash podcasts or by searching Hot Take Down in your favorite podcast app. 99% of visible is the aforementioned Katie Mingle Plus, Kurt Coles that Sheree Fusef, Sam Greenspan, Avery Trollman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, Delaney Hall, and me Roman Mars.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。感谢所有在筹款期间捐款的美丽书呆子们，非常感谢，也感谢《Pogister》杂志和Fresh Books提供的慷慨挑战赠款，激励我们在清晨时分达成了目标。听众的支持让我们变得强大，并帮助我们尝试新事物。没有你们，就不会有Radio-topia。你可以在Facebook上找到节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI。
We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. To all the beautiful nerds out there who donated during our fundraiser, thank you so much and thanks to Pogister Magazine and Fresh Books for putting up generous challenge grants that motivated us to hit our goals in the wee hours of the morning. Our listener support makes us strong and helps us try new things. It wouldn't be radio-topia without you. You can find the show in join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 999PI-ORG.
我们在Instagram和Tumblr上也有账号。但所有99PI相关事宜的中心是99pi.org。Radio-topia。来自PRX。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
We're on Instagram and Tumblr too. But the Nexus of all things 99PI is at 99pi.org. Radio to PI. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Instagram和Tumblr上。但99PI所有内容的中心是99pi.org。Radio to PI。来自PRX。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。